good hello everyone
how many have we got in the room
[Music]
nine of us i think yeah nine of us okay
i guess
i'm guessing that's how many were meant
to have so um my name's sarah mills i'm
locality development manager for casper
in rockford ccg and kelly and sarah have
um
invited me to facilitate this session um
so um there's a slide deck that i will
um
that i will go through do we want to do
does everybody know each other
in this um space do you want to do a
quick uh round of introductions i know
that we've all said hello
earlier but um just so that we know
who's round the table as it were
but that makes sense so um can
i i just need to find my participants um
so um uh shall we start with julie
sawford
yeah hello everybody yeah my name is
julie sawford i'm a family and community
worker at the mega centre and i've
worked with scotland with the
community response hub over the last few
months brilliant julie thank you
ben hello benbrook
castle point briar council strategy
policy and performance manager
thanks ben caroline hi everyone
acting ceo for southeastern central
essex mind offering mental health
services
in southend castle point and chelmsford
thanks caroline lindsey
hello i'm lindsay gillingham head of
operations at cavs
thanks lindsay victoria hi
i'm victoria marzuki and i'm the manager
at rams
thanks victoria i've got ceo mega center
yeah i need to change that
um when i go to the meetings i need to
change it i have a name my name
my name is carl williamson i am the ceo
of the make center
um absolutely we've been quite keen
instrumental in the community
response hub for rdc and working
partnership with the people
and obviously head up the mega center in
all of our community things that we do
thank you did you say carl was your
first name scott
is my name's scott i don't know where i
got carl from i just i just made it up
oh that's fine no no i'll stick with
scott thank you scott
um elizabeth hey there um i'm
taking the notes today and recording the
session from rdc
thanks elizabeth and councillor webb
yeah
hi there good morning councilman mike
webb community's portfolio holder for
watchful council and also just changed
scott's name to scott
thank you
can i just sarah yes
can i just what is victoria i can't just
apologize
i do have a face but i haven't got my
video on because
my little son's running around so i'm
sorry about that everyone but um
it's just safeguarding that's all okay
that's no problem victoria that is the
realities of uh lockdown life
and uh we're just glad to have you
right so i think we've got about 30
minutes for this conversation
so um i've got some slides which i'm
going to share
um i'm not going to go through them and
present them but um i think they are
um a start of a 10 in terms of our
conversation so i will just pop them up
if that's okay
um so
can everybody see my screen yep yep
okay so we are the community resilience
workshop
i think we're all here because we have a
vested interest
in um building and strengthening our
communities
and so it's it's a this is a kind of new
priority
area community resilience um
and so i think that probably the slide
deck for this particular conversation
looks a little bit different to the
slide decks for other conversations
um we have got some data it's mainly
their community hub data
i don't want to spend too much time uh
looking at that really because i think
that
we've had a really good update in the
main meeting
um around uh the kind of amazing work
that's been going on across castle point
and russia from a voluntary perspective
um
throughout covid um it's pretty humbling
to to hear what an amazing job
everybody's been doing
um so um so it's just to say really i
suppose that um
community resilience is is becoming a
priority area in its own right
um it's probably absolutely crucial
to um the future of um of the kind of
localities and health and well-being of
the population who live
in castle point and rochford um and uh
building on some of the work that's
already happened as a result of covid
but i think that
historically there's been a really good
community engagement across castlepoint
and rochford
and so um is something that we we need
to formalize
in terms of the health and well-being
offer um and something that we need to
work together in partnership to deliver
so um just a quick
uh kind of few questions for you to
sort of ruminate on whilst looking at
the data what does it tell us
are there any key themes um and what's
the current situation
and now what's the future look like in
terms of community
resilience for caterpillar and rockford
so
this is uh the operation shield data
um they've got the essex y data and
castle point and rockford
i think the key thing for me that comes
out of this is just the absolute volume
of support that was offered
and obviously um we've got scott and
julie and victoria on the call
um are there anything anything that you
want to draw out of the data um
obviously there's a number of data
slides do you shall i flick through them
all and then we can
we can kind of talk about what the
meaning might be is that helpful
yeah absolutely these are the breakdown
of category a
and registered and unregistered users
um can see where they are by
ward um again that's the same for
rochford registered and unregistered
category a users
vulnerable residents um again registered
and
unregistered so i think there's that um
understanding that we know who some of
these people are but we don't know who
all of them are
same for rochford registered vulnerable
and registered vulnerable are those
unregistered vulnerable people
really difficult to to find to help to
offer support to
to access um and then this is the essex
welfare service
so we've got that broken down by
watchford and castlepoint
and you can see the essex picture at the
top
um so that's the kind of that's the very
high level overview
of um of data during covid
obviously the data set that we have for
community resilience
is somewhat limited um because it's a
new priority area we don't have that
historical
collection of data also it's i think a
much more difficult
um thing to quantify physical health
you can kind of quantify that who's
accessing services he's accessing what
who's obese
there's kind of lots of um of data
around that community resilience
is a little bit more intangible a bit
more qualitative
and a bit more around perceptions rather
than
facts so um i'd just like to draw out
some of those
um feelings and thoughts from all of you
in response to um
your experience of the last few months
of community and voluntary offer
locally would anyone like to start
um scott do you have anything does the
data
look familiar to you yeah it does look
very familiar
the numbers are quite high um i think
for me
i think we certainly obviously i can't
speak from a
brought from the district rather than
the castle point but saying that we do
work in castle point as it makes it as
well
is the we we presume that we are very
i think one thing that struck me really
in all of this is
is the isolation in our community
is is phenomenal and actually
the isolation even though we think we
live in a vibrant community where people
connect with each other
i think the isolation was part of people
and the vulnerability of people
who don't don't feel able for whatever
reason
to connect him with the services that we
have in our community
that would be the thing for so the
number of people that
were isolating themselves because they
just felt that they were not able to
connect into the
to the the resources in our community
via healthcare be it whatever
was quite stagnant to me um the amount
of people i spoke to i've spoken to
hundreds
over the last six months that was quite
telling for me that we've got fantastic
services but
i'm not sure they're aware of all them
and they don't connect into them and i
would love to know the reasons
why that is do you feel like you
you don't have a sense of why that is
then i think i do i think
i think i do but it might be my
perspective my perspective of it i'd
rather hear
i'd rather work out while their reasons
were i think i have my reasons obviously
i'm married to gp who works in the area
as well and i think i have my
perspectives of why i think that is
well that's mine i'm coming from a very
different position than they're coming
from
yeah you know the older generation it
was work we don't need it you know we're
julian i was being some
eighteen ninety-one people you know why
us
uh you know we don't need that give it
to somebody else don't give it to us
so i think if i was to share
perspectives i think it'd be my
perspective rather than what they think
and when you actually try to speak to
the restless
on the phone which i probably spoke
about are probably about
300 400 residents in the whole of the
last four months
one facebook page on the phone they were
very
resilient to actually give that input to
you
in an informal way which is quite
telling as well
yeah no i agree i think um there is a
lot of um
older people who think um you know i
don't need help i've managed all this
time and you know this is fine
or if they help somebody else who needs
it
and also people um i did speak to quite
a few people and took food parcels to
people who
almost felt really embarrassed at the
thought of having to accept help
because they've always managed um and
this has obviously hit them quite hard
and
um you know like all of us we all need
help at times
um in different forms um and um
it's getting that message across as well
that there's nothing wrong
with having help i think the key thing
for us as well because we worked in
partnerships
i think that was really really really
really helpful certainly from rdc point
of view because we had the council
we had the community we had the we had
the churches
we had volunteers and i think that was
really really powerful because you had
some
say well i don't i and i'm a i'm an
ordained vicar so i can say this
i don't want the church bringing me
anything what the journey ever bloody
done for me sort of thing
yeah i had that and i went oh i'm
but because we had a different we had a
good representation of all those
different communities working together
what we had was people say well i don't
want to get anything from the church
well it's an optional district council
thing some people say i don't want
anything for the council
really really helpful really really
helpful yeah
so something the strength is the the
total offer is greater than the sum of
its parts basically
100 percent yeah and i think that was
really helpful for me i know what kind
of
things that was really really powerful
and you didn't have people
saying well i don't want anything for
the council i don't want to open the
church but actually because we are
working together
i think we helped a lot more people i
think part of what you said and i'm
picking up on what you said really um i
saw some slides yesterday that mike
goggity shared about unemployment data
in
the county actually and what was
interesting
is that um at the start of lockdown
tendrin had
a relatively high unemployment level and
rochford didn't
um and as we progressed through furlough
and through the crisis
the unemployment level in rochford
reached a point that it's not reached in
quite a long time and i'm just wondering
if
as a district and i can't speak because
the point i was kind of focusing on the
watchful data
but certainly in rochford that data was
quite exceptional
we've not had that kind of level of
unemployment before and maybe that feeds
into people
not wanting to accept help not wanting
to accept food parcels
because actually as a district we've not
been in that position before
whereas other parts of the county have
been in that position before
and mike gawkert's data i thought was
actually quite interesting and how it
kind of
showed um well historically there's been
high levels of unemployment and
tendering was specifically mentioned and
yet
now we've got that same issue to some
extent
within rochford and i think that's where
the community struggles to adapt
to being in a very different place to
where
it has been before and how do you think
that's going to impact on
what the community needs from
not only its statutory services but also
its voluntary services and thinking
about that
hello sorry sarah i think it's the
rising
in the need of food banks and future
work has got to be
food banks are not the norm food banks
are not acceptable
yeah do you know that's continuing so
what can we do to build
people through budgeting through
apprenticeships through offering them
volunteering
and upskilling so that they do have the
ability to
find work when it's available and that
what can we do to support them either
with man in the pan
cooking courses whatever it takes to be
able to
make them not reliant on food banks but
use the food banks to identify those
families who then
go on to you know so that we can support
them in a different way
because the rising food banks and the
mutual
aid groups that set up during the
pandemic to be able to distribute food
were extreme not just in this county but
nationwide
so i think that's something we can focus
on
but just to go back to to what scott and
julian
and mike have said we could not have
made the success of the hub and help the
people
if it wasn't a partnership approach we
couldn't have done it on our own
that's the point and i think that is one
of the key learnings
is the partnership is the strength so
so in terms of thinking thinking about
the strategy then in terms of the
strategy
um the one of the essential tenets of
community
resilience is partnership working is
that would you agree with that
i think so and also i think so what we
didn't do there wasn't any stronger
person at the table
which is really quite helpful there
wasn't so obviously didn't call the
shops i didn't call the shots
um you know the churches together
because we we
didn't have a it was just a mutual we're
all at the same level at the table okay
and actually for once it wasn't about
what we could gain
because we were trying to deal with the
crisis navy's agenda was
was was a priority and actually that was
very apparent i felt
that we weren't trying to sort so well i
particularly back in my organization
and that was very um very aware very
obvious and also
what victoria said i think victoria is a
really really key thing victoria
and one thing we're looking at here is
actually obviously we see the data on
the daily basis
is we're looking at okay how do we train
people in
we're going to do the job bank probably
here at the main center we're probably
going to do caps so money management
so how can we how can we help people at
this crisis and actually a lot of the
older people as well we're looking for
an older person thing at the center
which we've never done before
we're looking to say well actually how
did we do some skill sets basic cookery
i used to
check before i was thinking about how do
we do basic cookery where you can make a
meal on so you can make a meal out
of ingredients of two pounds how can you
how can you
budget a bit better than you do so what
we're looking at is that's why i say
going forward is right what are the
needs that came up and why do people go
to the food bank what we can we can do
to
to try and stop them from doing doing
that giving
their to help with that we're looking
just probably
we're working with the food bank here
ready but we're looking to put a program
together
or probably financial stuff and
budgeting
how to cook on a budget uh how to how to
cook on a budget how to live on a budget
and and how to and we're going to try
and put a package together to deliver on
some of that and that's come out of
that's come out of the quote that's come
out of the korean virus helpline
come out of that so actually we're
giving people a tool now when they come
to that
i think they will become lesser
that's easier for some people to do than
go to the food bank because quite a few
people find it hard
india and can i ask a question around
the relationship with
health services um throughout covid
and just thinking about you know
obviously um uh cavs have had a really
pivotal role
through their social prescribers in
terms of linking the
primary care offer with the voluntary
um offer and what people need um but
going forward
um do you think that there's there's an
opportunity
above non-social prescribers to bring
health
and and the kind of all broader
community partners together
um because you know identifying people
who might have specific needs or who
might be particularly vulnerable
who perhaps as you yourselves said right
at the beginning that
maybe don't feel like they can feel
comfortable
accessing services is there a kind of in
reach element or some kind of
um shared list of vulnerable people that
could
that could work bring voluntary and
health services together
and social services to work more
seamlessly
one thing that i would have liked to
have done sarah which i
have done my wife now works as a gp and
pixie but she used to be audi mills
one thing i would have loved to have
done is i would have loved to
within our sort of radio in our district
i would love to have got
the partners from our you know getting
the gps together
some of the partners and i spoke to my
wife about it extensively and she's well
you can come and speak to us as partners
in petsy but we're a bit
uh they're out of options but i think
that would have been a really helpful
thing you know
and i think that would have been really
helpful for us to do it in our learning
you know in the doctor i've got about
our learning certainly from an rdc
perspective
um to actually see how we could have
linked in somehow with
you know the the gps or even the
partners of some of the big gp practices
and actually had a dialogue and
conversation with them because i think
it would be beneficial both sides
and that's something about our learning
that we want to try and explore a little
bit
in the future i'm just on that note i'm
going to
share a slide with you from further down
the deck
because i realized we kind of started
off talking about the data but actually
we've talked about
more broadly but i want to share this
with you can you see
that screen not at the moment
is it coming oh hang on maybe i'm not
sharing my screen
am i sharing my screen i'm not saying
this video at the moment
i'm sharing the wrong screen that's what
i'm doing
is it there yeah yeah okay so um
this is something that's come out of
conversations um with a variety of
partners across
um southeast essex um he put our
community health provider
and primary care um and and other
kind of partners
and this is a kind of vision really for
locality leadership
and around bringing together and really
being very inclusive
around having um leaders from
the localities so community
organizations such as yourself
alongside residents and faith leaders
alongside health social care mental
health
um leaders to create a kind of locality
leadership function um that would
kind of direct the the strategy and and
the
ways in which partnership sort of
formalize that partnership working
really
and get everybody engaged it would be
very very important that there was
exactly as you described earlier scott
that kind of parity of esteem for people
who were sitting at the table so
everybody felt like they had an equal
voice
um and that the needs that they
recognized and and evidenced in
in the locality were as important as
health needs or social care needs and
recognizing that actually
what the work that the community sector
can do
um can actually happen more upstream and
can
prevent some of those um can prevent
some of those
crises and urgent care needs happening
um and i'm kind of just to reflect that
the slide
earlier so this um this is a kind of
thinking about how
we provide support on a on a kind of
locality
population level so thinking about that
would be for example
ben fleet or canby um or rochford
um and that you know there are
people who have the highest needs which
is the complex
people who need health and social care
um and probably you know a whole host of
services and support wrapping around
them maybe some of them are at the end
of life
then there's those people who have
ongoing care needs so those are people
who
are maybe frail or have a long-term
condition or a number of long-term
conditions who
need regular interface with their gp
or even with hospital services then
there's urgent care needs so that's
where people somebody has a stroke
or somebody has um you know a health
crisis a health event or even a social
care crisis
um and and they need a lot of support um
but for a short period of time
and the idea is is if that urgent care
need is met
effectively um that they can move back
into that bottom
population tier which is where community
resilience comes
in so um this is about you know looking
at the assets within a locality
um that enable a population to stay well
it really focuses on that prevention
agenda so you know
supporting people to take healthy
behaviors
making sure that planning decisions um
are mindful of health and well-being
needs
um you know health promoting
environments infrastructures
active travel for example um ben's on
the caller i'm
i'm sure he um he's got some thoughts
around this but that's
that's where this element of the health
and well-being strategy really focuses
is on that whole population asset based
prevention
um and really creating healthy
environments for people to lead
healthy lives within um and and the idea
would be that that
leadership model um could
help to drive this and make sure that
all partners
are working together so that when
someone tips from
whole population through an urgent care
need and may in fact then need
ongoing care needs that that breadth of
need can be met
not just by health but also by social
care but
also by um you know
the voluntary sector the community
wrapping around
somebody support you know promoting good
neighbors
that all of those things i know that you
do already but
but at the moment some of those things
are happening in isolation in silos and
trying to bring that together
so that you as a community organization
are well hooked into your local gp
uh surgeries and and the primary care
network
hello is everything all right yes it's
fine
sorry no it's okay i thought i'd said
something really controversial
and i thought what have i done what have
i said
so i'd be really keen to get your
thoughts um on that
um i'm gonna stop sharing my screen um
so i can see you all again um
any thoughts on on that kind of model
and
and how you feel like you could play a
part to bring that into being
i have some but i want other people to
speak so i spoke too much
about others um
can you hear me i'm happy to come in i
think from my perspective i think that
i think for you know one of the things
that we've we've learned in castle point
is about that sort of that
that specialism a little bit i think of
support i think i alluded to
in the presentation about how you know
most of the community organizations out
there can actually turn their hands to
most things you know extremely adaptable
extremely resilient and
you know be able to sort of react
quickly in a crisis and i think that's
what we saw happen in castle point
i think i think i think there is that
there is something around the
coordination you know there's an
understanding of what that offer is and
which organization's the best place to
provide which
support but i think an understanding of
that and the coordination of that and
you know and where that coordination
takes place i think it's probably
something that we do need to
we do need to sort of almost get to the
bottom of you know is it
is the gp surgery the place where
actually most people first go
when when when you know when when they
want to talk to somebody
is it is it you know is it a different
organization is is it cavs is it ravs
you know
that coordinating role should that very
much sit with them
um these are any sort of thoughts you
know but but i
i i i think they're important to get to
the bottom of actually and i think i
think a lot of the time it is about that
navigating through the system actually
you know i know we have sort of you know
expressions around sort of care
navigation etc etc and i think there is
an element here actually you know
community community sector navigation
for one of a better expression i think
just in terms of you know in terms of
being able to sort of understand what
that local offer is
and the organizations within that local
offer being able to understand what each
other does and i think that's where the
partnership thing came in really really
strongly actually
and that's where you know perhaps not
initially but certainly later on you
know
it's in this over in the time period
since lockdown
there was a lot more communication i
think between the
community and voluntary organizations
talking with each other and getting to
know each other a little bit better i
think that was really really powerful
yeah thank you yeah thank you yeah i
would agree with everything that's
already been said and also
keep losing my earpiece sorry um and
also
um uh it's not just health i think
um it's where as you say wherever
anybody goes to get some support
you know with families it might be at
the school with people with uh
preschoolers it might be at the
children's central family husband
they're known now um so it could be any
of those organizations all the voluntary
ones
um and um i think i think in the past
um working not just for the mega center
but for other charities
as i have done in my career um i think
there's also been
an element of of i think
can we rely on smaller organizations to
always be there
um but i think the partnership that we
have now um
is stronger than that um as you say
as a partnership we're really strong and
only getting stronger
um so the partnership is what is able to
support the community
rather than individual organizations
within that
um but as i say i think it's not just
gps it's wherever anybody goes to get
some support
even if it's a poster on the wall in the
library or something
um just where somebody thinks that they
might be able to get a listening ear or
just a bit of signposting
i think i think that's for you i think
that point that you make about
sustainability and resilience of
community office absolutely key
um i kind of like to open that up to
victoria and lindsay
um because you know obviously as a as a
association of voluntary sector
voluntary services you have a
i suppose a role to play in that
sustainability and resilience of the
community sector i don't i just wondered
whether you had any thoughts about that
really
i think the point is it's about getting
the message out to places where people
go
if people you know the point that scott
made earlier was the point that
people don't want the help people don't
want to ask for the help but people
needed the help
so do we put leaflets in taxis do we put
something in
the local hairdressers do we
i don't know get people to put posters
in
tea shop whatever places where people go
where they will get the information but
they won't have to actually find it or
make it more obvious
i don't think yes but people usually
only approach voluntary services when
they're either in crisis
or they already know about us because
one of the things rav picked up on
was during the pandemic which has been a
real positive for us
oh i didn't know you were here i didn't
know you did that
what was the other thing i didn't
realize you were so small you know was
another brilliant one but
yes i know so the point is is that i
don't think it's just about using
voluntary services
the resilience for the community sarah
has to come
has to come from a commercial element as
well now
okay yeah but his name
is so different aren't they and and
indeed from our experience across the
board
someone has to be ready to accept help
so if they've got mental capacity
and even though all of us can know or
think
what help they need they have to be
ready to accept it
and i think what we've got to be mindful
of is
not having too much information out in
the community
get confused um you know i think the
good news is with the
pcn wellbeing link coordinators is
that you know part of their role is is
linking in with all the different
partner agencies and as a cvs
we've already got a membership base
anyway um
you know a strength of ours is that you
know if we can't personally help we know
someone who can
and we all you know we sit on enough
different boards
to know that if if we come across
something we wasn't sure of or
couldn't find an agency then there's
always somebody to mask
you know i think it's a from covid
perspective
and dare i say a generational thing but
yeah
in general the older generation i think
the way they were brought up
is they're very appreciative of um the
offering so
you know some of them needed a bit of
encouragement of you know don't worry
about that we hope to support you
you know if you need that food we'll get
it for you um
i'm very very grateful um you know i
don't want to generalize but the
younger generation has a totally
different attitude
i'm not saying all the older generation
we're the same because i know we come
across a few that
um you know it's almost i deserve it
i've paid my money and i deserve this
help
so um you know i think
the strength is our partnership work the
knowledge
that we have the skills that everybody
has and you know the collaborative
working i think you're already doing it
and i know from our point of view we are
already linking with the educational
settings
um but i think this goes back to
not only individual people accepting
help but also
different um partner agencies
remembering the agencies are there to
help
i think everybody's become so busy quite
naturally
um and sometimes they do know you're all
available and we're all available but
they're so you know drawn into that
moment of what they're doing and they
forget oh actually i can signpost them
to
whomever because i think like victoria
i i find it quite interesting when
people say oh i didn't know you were
there
really anybody you know
um in the community
um and i remember a few of our clients
saying
oh oh your cats are you i've heard about
it
yeah and i suppose that that's one of
the silver linings of covert isn't it is
that everybody's profile has been
raised slightly
hello we've got five minutes left by the
way
i know i i saw that i'm i was just about
to go on scott please
i don't know if we should share them
with our secrets with this group i feel
we should um a little bit you know we
are
seriously considering as a mega center
okay some of you know us we do soft play
laser
but victoria will know a bit about this
because we've had conversations
it's actually we're mortgage free now
it's trying to within rdc district
trying to make this sense of community
help
out of the back of out of the back of
coronavirus so what we would have is
voluntary sector people having offices
here us having offices here
um cgc have not you know or ccg all and
actually having a place with a coffee
shop
and a place where people can just come
right so if you come into this space
there's a
there's enough facilities to hire outs
all those organizations can hire out the
facilities to use
but there's also offices so that we have
a realistic
coalition of partnership together now
now that's just a crazy thought
but it's certainly something that we are
seriously considering
is that but we've been here for 27 years
we've done laser soft play and we've had
an impact
in our charity but might say that maybe
those times have had their day
and the next thing is out at the back of
covid is to have
you know dare i say it we might even be
speaking to gp surgery
to have a surgery here as well you know
just having that whole thing that
you have a hub where we're all together
and i think
that's come out of coving for us and
it's come out partnership for us now
how that will work so do you think of us
because we're having those really
crazy ideas but i think there's some i
think there's a lot better i've seen it
working in switzerland
and i've seen it working in south
america because the resources say it has
to work
because we all can't rent our own
facilities now we i think we're coming
to that stage a little bit here so it's
something we're exploring
that is music to my ears well let's have
a conversation because we want to make
it happen because i used to work in
south america
and we couldn't do it there because
people just they were too
poor for us all to have our own
facilities and so actually what we did
is we all worked together in the same
building in partnership
and actually what it did it just it just
it radically changed the
the community in which we worked in
although very very different very
different than radio and watchful
district very different
principles are really key i think covert
has told us
if clover is taught some things i think
is teaching us as a mega center
maybe there's a new way of doing what we
do
yeah thank you scott that's really
interesting i'm just going to share my
screen before we have to finish so this
is
um
well we've got 56 seconds for 56 seconds
or she gone
elizabeth did you just get with the
sarah i did i didn't i didn't i just i
was about to say